the king coming closer and he knows it
oh i know he's happy
i can't believe i just beat him oh my
god
yes
oh my gosh none of you none of you
thought i was gonna beat this man none
of you look at that that is right oh my
gosh
oh my god did anyone just see what i
just did
[Music]
so
done the calculations
[Music]
so now i'm in check okay you are getting
god's sake crazy with it
oh he's gonna now i think i checkmated
that's check so she hasn't already
i don't know if i made the right play i
don't know if i blundered i don't know
if i was doing something wrong but i
took my time there okay
and i did it
i didn't win i didn't win guys i didn't
celebration that you survived
she won the match minks won the match
everybody don't take the brook that's
the only thing you can't do
he's getting jiggy with it danny
it was incredible
eat the pain away i'm gonna take this
no no no no
oh my god
she's just karaoke and
i just
away my queen
that was pretty cool i hate myself now
maybe 14 coming
uh
i think my original plan is still the
good plan here
anna is an actual sniper that she's got
a massive rifle and she's probably
across the street just looking in my
window wouldn't it be hilarious if you
actually were kgb like if you knew it
imagine
robert has has uh has been incredible
like before every game i feel bad saying
this because now i realize i'm one of
the favorite children and not everybody
got this treatment but but yeah before
every game i was sent uh detailed uh uh
predictions of what was likely to unfold
this man in a previous pog champs helped
me refine this opening
and i feel
an insane sense of betrayal we gonna
make it happen i'm coming for the award
first time i played chess what's for
park champs four yeah yo hats you a good
coach i can't fry you got me up to speed
for only playing chess for one month
yeah we still in it my bars they
infinite when it comes to kicking revs
man i never been timid i told you we've
been having them epiphanies and it's an
honor to have played against mr beast
let's go
oh my gosh well it seems that rubius
copied me and andrea because we went to
put on suit jackets he did the same so
rubius what inspired the suit and tie
because you guys did it and as you know
i copy every english streamer
she resigned all right zero mistakes
zero blunders exactly what we're after
let's go man you played 97 accuracy do
you realize how
messed up that is
that is so bad i spent
you s you suck
you suck
he's trying no don't don't pre-move that
that is over sometimes
oh my god he could actually steal me no
this is really really bad
do not do that because what is happening
you can accidentally stalemate if you do
this the king might go the other way
buddy
oh
oh my god oh
oh no never mind no boxing no it's gonna
be a stalemate it's gonna be a stalemate
he's still there
oh my don't do it he's gonna do it don't
do it don't do it
yeah
i move
like a staircase
yes
oh
god
crazy
don't don't pre-move stop it don't wait
[Music]
that was so close
even i draw the 5 up would have still
won the match take notes wow he wins you
you you put out the best fight you could
and i'm proud of you for the progress
you made but honestly from the beginning
i don't think we stood a chance against
five up i'm not gonna lie when you asked
me how much training you could do in my
head i was like there's no amount we're
screwed it's over wow damn i just
believed in you
he was messed up well that's not coach
mentality at all what kind of what the
hell was that i'm just being a realist
i know
i watched a murder
i'm gonna eat you in a little bit little
banana
i'm gonna restore my potassium i thought
you were talking to the producer for a
second
i thought
will you see queen h4
listen in
oh my god
right before my stream started i you
started your stream already and the
title is today we beat fundy and chess
yeah what happened
how do i leave the interview how do i
leave
these guys we're friends fund me having
no mercy is it gonna be if he plays
check he wants to draw
don't do it
oh
[Laughter]
god danny's so hot we don't we don't
need to do any turtle play of the game
because we got tie breaks we don't know
what the eternal place why no why are
you replaying that but you can type why
no why are you playing that why no
fly okay i'm leaving all right hey
that's a good stream all right let's go
straight okay i'll be leaving all right
it's been fun all right i donated a
thousand dollars to his stream and
intermission uh to hopefully distract
him a little bit he's gonna be thinking
so much about their donation he's not
gonna be focused on this game of chess
triple big brain iq moves
mr penis
what the [__]
oh
my heart
i wonder i i don't know what anyone's
talking about right now
you
absolute god he said you absolute god
there we go
who said you can't pay for wins and
chips
invite me back to your damn tournament i
lost it was it was a it was
i made it further than you i'm playing
more things
i know it was i had a bad setup all
right
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
move
again oh
no
oh my gosh
oh no
no that was that dick climatic oh wow
well now i feel bad because i feel like
he intentionally still made it the
second game to make up for my stalemate
[Music]
yeah
dude
holy
yes
oh my god this should look good on you
gold looks good on you
yeah no it does it does wait wait wait
wait wait
it does oh my god oh he does oh my god
he's wrong he does look good on me he's
gonna be matching and just fully dripped
out thousand dollar donation nineteen
thousand five hundred dollars from
someone
wow
from hotshot gg
we threw some we threw some subs you
guys away but not 19 500 work that is
amazing thank you so much we have now
raised more than we did for pogchamps 3.
this is the most wow just.com has ever
raised for a single event
for charity
[Music]